okay I grab your attention please the
degradation of result of selection of a
member of parliament that all of them
Eastern Sabbath on Thursday May 13 2017
I currently work in being the acting
returning officer at the above election
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Abraham's
Debbie Labour Party twenty five thousand
six hundred and twenty nine the
Conservative Party founded seventy
thousand four hundred and forty seven
[Applause]
party you get 2278 Smith
Jonathan Hall Liberal Democrat 1683
projection was a follow quantum official
mark zero voting for more candidates and
voters in time for 215 writing will mark
by which voter could be identified zero
the unmarked or wholly more uncertainty
89 that over 104 and I do hereby declare
that Debbie Abraham's is duly elected as
the Member of Parliament for the eastern
suburbs
[Applause]
and containment I just want to say big
thank you to the returning officer and
all the staff here for staying up and
doing such an amazing job to the police
as well for maintaining order my agent
film and my amazing team including Lucy
who spearheaded my campaign with Hart
freed carring Saba Marcia George and
John Chloe and Amy who campaign in
between their exams to the hundreds of
members and activists and you know who
you are
including the volunteer who said that
they were more than happy to do some
more leafletting tomorrow to everyone
who voted for me including Karen's mama
who was sick and Pauline couldn't you
know is worried that she wouldn't be
able to vote and she managed to get up
and vote
so mrs. McDonald he was in bed but when
we knocked and said there's election on
she got up and went to the polling
station and mrs. Patel enclosed a shop
early to make sure that she could go and
vote I'm really grateful to you for
showing such trust and confidence and I
won't let you down and can I just say a
big thank you to my family comes out
without whose support I just would not
be able to do this so this is I'm really
really grateful to all of you this
election has defied all polls and all
predictions there will be time for
reflections and analyses but I believe
our manifesto spoke to people of all
ages of all backgrounds it resonated
that with them for a desire for a fair
audible Saddleworth in a fairer country
and I will work tirelessly to deliver
that for you thank you so much again
you
[Applause]